make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and the
loki trailer just
dropped yesterday out of nowhere which
is a really nice birthday gift i really
enjoyed it
uh but they also paid a little more or
gave us a little more information about
the time variance authority and so what
i'm gonna do in this video is i'm gonna
make you an expert on the time variance
authority
in under 30 minutes as i always do here
on comics explained and i think what you
guys are going to find
is the multiverse is a lot more
interesting than it originally seems
right so
a lot of you guys i imagine are probably
coming here from like the marvel
cinematic universe films right you're
watching falcon in the winter soldier or
you've seen one division or you've seen
doctor strange
and on the surface especially if you see
doctor strange the multiverse looks
simple right like if you're looking at
avengers end game or something like that
you have the ancient one talking to the
incredible hulk and saying like you know
if you don't put the stones back
at the proper time everything could go
awry and and it's it's easy to look at
the multiverse and just say okay like
it's a collection of universes
that is not true that is not true by any
standard of measurement there are
all kinds of moving parts and all kinds
of groups and organizations that exist
out there to safeguard the multiverse so
to kind of break these things down right
let's start with like the living
tribunal for example the living tribunal
was created by the one above all as a
means to essentially safeguard the
multiverse right to make sure
that mystical balance is maintained now
when the living tribunal was originally
introduced it was just
magical energy right because he was
originally a doctor strange character as
time progressed in marvel comics and you
saw the living tribunal becoming more
and more involved it was really more to
just maintain the natural order of the
universe whatever that happened to be
he kind of became a plot device more or
less and that's what you'll find with a
lot of these things
but then you started seeing the
introduction of like merlin and the
captain britain core
so merlin is like this wildly magical
being who created the captain britain
core for the purpose of safeguarding
every universe against whatever threats
may emerge the realities of the captain
written core
is is really really weak um they're not
really that powerful
you would need lots of them in order to
safeguard a particular universe so one
captain britain kind of sucks
in comparison to pretty much almost any
major threat out there you know for
example captain britain could probably
not defeat the incredible hulk and
that's just a really strong guy on earth
imagine like the molecule man owen reese
who could alter reality on a multiversal
scale
you know so from there you go into
what's called like the omni russell
development court and that
is a group that's led by a woman named
saturnine or saturn 9 if you want to
pronounce it that way she's what's
called the omniversal matrix so she
leads the group and their whole role is
to make sure that like
mutants across the multiverse that like
in every on every earth in every
universe
mutants gain their powers at around the
same time that every universe has its
own version of the avengers that
universes develop the way that they're
supposed to and if a universe does not
they initiate something called the push
and that's what happened in earth 238
when they
didn't realize that jim jasper had
killed all the superheroes on earth and
then when they initiated the push he
took it as a threat
and then altered reality and basically
twisted the universe to such a degree
that they had to destroy it
then you go into groups like the exiles
right the exiles are just kind of a
collection of
uh different characters from alternate
realities who just sort of travel from
one universe to the next facing off
against various threats you have adam
berscher's ultimate avengers so like a
multiversal avengers team so that's like
the blue marvel it's uh carol danvers
it's black panther
um monaco rambo america chavez people
like that
it's a really cool team but it's a
really really cool concept and then you
have the time variance
authority so the time variance authority
originally appeared back in thor issue
number 372
in 1986 and was created by walt simonsen
but the the idea of the time variance
authority as it was originally given to
us
was not fully fleshed out instead what
you had here was a guy by the name of
justice peace and justice peace was a
guy from an alternate reality
where earth was basically a giant mega
city called brooklynophilus
and the whole idea behind this is that
world war seven had essentially begun
when the last holdouts which were a kind
of a bridge between the panama canal and
patagonia when that whole process
was disrupted due to attack by a villain
by the name of zaniac
and so because the representative there
had been killed it was considered an act
of war and the missiles were flying and
everything was popping off and so
justice peace ended up getting
permission from the time variants
authority to travel back into the past
into the main marvel universe and then
to basically
destroy zaniac which with the help of
thor he was able to do
of course there was a bit of a skirmish
between the two at first
because they didn't fully trust each
other um but then following that you
know we kind of got
a little more involvement from the time
variance authority in different stories
for example if you go and you look at
avengers annual you find out that the
time variance authority had kind of
created robots that were designed to
sort of help them maintain the timelines
and ultimately the robots just kind of
went awry right and things just kind of
popped off from there
uh and then of course you had like power
man and iron fist which is kind of a
continuation to a degree not
directly but kind of a loose
continuation of avengers annual number
22
um and then you kind of go into the
fantastic four era and the fantastic
four era is really where you learn the
most about the time variance authority
in terms of their full form and function
how they work all that kind of stuff
we never really get an origin for them
it's just kind of one of those things
where they just popped up one day and
they're just they just kind of exist to
protect the timelines and that's
essentially it now the funny thing about
this is that with walt simonsen being
the one to create the tva
and thor it made perfect sense that as
the person who was writing fantastic
four at the time he would continue that
theme going
and so with fantastic four issues 338
through 345 going into fantastic four
annual number 24 that what you got was
this story involving something called a
time bubble and the time bubble had been
referenced in thor 372 but this is when
we actually saw the the full totality of
what was going on
alongside the idea that the time
variance authority would actually
contract
out in this instance it was a guy by the
name of death's head now the
the time bubble as it was given to us in
thor 372 was simply just
kind of established as a mistake that
was made by the tva but we didn't really
know the details of it
instead what we get in fantastic four
over the course of these stories is this
idea that somewhere along the line
galactus had basically been defeated
right galactus was believed to have been
killed and what you got was what was
called the black celestial which
resurrected galactus and then
exacerbated his hunger and so what ended
up happening is galactus kind of took
off to a point in the universe and then
created a black hole in order to kind of
pull all matter towards him and then
consume that matter
so he was just basically super lazy is
really all it was instead of traveling
around from world to world like he
normally does he just pulled everything
to him by creating this black hole now
the tva
investigated it and actually ended up
exacerbating it and so what ended up
happening is they kind of quarantined
this area
off and the 15-year time bubble
basically meant that within this sphere
time was basically stopped right i mean
i guess it kind of continued on in its
own way
and so if you decided to time travel and
you ended up back or kind of running
into that bubble
you could potentially get trapped but
according to the tva once they kind of
walled it off you would just sort of run
into a roadblock right and it'd be super
hard to get past it and so the fantastic
four alongside iron man 2020 and a
couple other characters from different
realities
ended up investigating the time bubble
and when they did they realized this
alternate reality version of galactus
was inside of it and so what reid
richards did is he brought in something
called the ultimate nullifier now for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with this
the ultimate nola fire is a very old
artifact in marvel comics and in fact it
originally showed up in the old galactus
trilogy by stanley and jack kirby but
this is a device that it's its power is
relative to the person who wields it if
you have the ultimate nullifier in your
possession but you're not super
intelligent and you don't have
a very very strong constitution then you
might be able to do something like
destroy a car
but if you're somebody like reed
richards who's highly intelligent and
has a very high amount of constitution
you can use the ultimate nullifier to
its full potential which is to basically
erase something from existence and when
i say erase it from existence
it's basically as if it never existed in
the first place right so
if i use the ultimate nullifier on you
then not only would you cease to exist
nobody would remember you none of the
teachers would have ever encountered you
right this is if you just
never existed in the first place and so
the ultimate nullifier is a pretty
serious weapon
that's only used in the most extreme
situations but because the time bubble
was one of these things where it would
eventually become a threat to the
multiverse itself reed richards used the
ultimate nullifier on that reality's
version of galactus and wiped him from
existence
this goes directly into fantastic four
issues 352
running all the way up to 354 which
basically had the fantastic four brought
before the time variance authority to
kind of explain themselves and this is
when you end up
kind of finding out the nature of the
tva right the the more detailed uh role
that the tva plays and exactly how it is
that they function
so i think we'll find this to be a lot
easier to digest
if we kind of compare it to what's going
on in the loki's show at least what
we've seen
right so at the very top of the company
because the time variance authority
treats itself more like a corporation
than anything else
you have a guy named mr alternity and
you don't really see a whole lot of this
guy in fact i think the only real time
you've ever seen him was in fantastic
four annual number 27
and marvel knights vol 4 issue number
18. right so this guy's kind of the top
of the chain right he's like the boss
the ceo
the whole nine yards under him you have
mobius m mobius this is the guy owen
wilson plays in the loki tv show but
this guy
is the second in command and kind of a
funny thing the way it played out in
fantastic four
uh 352 and 353 is that you actually had
this explanation that was given to them
by mobius and mobius in terms of how the
tva works
that was actually well really the only
reason it was given was because of
sharon ventura
sharon ventura was a woman who got her
powers from the power broker right she
went by the name miss marvel for a
little while so kind of a fun little way
to tie into falcon in the winter soldier
i don't think you'll see
sharon ventura in uh in loki it'd be
kind of cool if you did
but she was more or less a character
that kind of was rolled into the
fantastic four
and then eventually became a spy for
doctor doom against the fantastic four
so uh there's there's a little too much
history there to really invoke her but
you might see her there she's kind of
interesting but the way this whole
explanation is given
by mobius and mobius is that the time
variance authority
exists for the purpose of monitoring and
safeguarding timelines
now i mean the reality is because
stories like age of ultron days of
future past you know
the michael korvac saga because stuff
like that exists they suck at their jobs
but the the time variance authority
exists in a realm outside of the
multiverse right kind of like their own
little dimensional space that's there
and one of the things is first
established one of the first things that
we're told is they do have their own
time cops now one thing to understand is
that the the
tva having its own police force is not a
catch-all right it's not an end-all i
mean the the various forces that exist
out there with enough power to influence
or even create new timelines
are wide and varying right the exile
superhero team the beyonder the molecule
man owen reese the beyonders themselves
the marquee of death
matthew malloy you've got various people
out there even the scarlet witch right
you've got various people out there that
are capable of altering realities
in that way uh and so because the amount
of power they possess almost none of
these cops would be able to stand
against them
these cops that exist here are really
they really exist more for the purpose
of tracking down individuals who are
manipulating time
through things like technological means
right so they they invented some kind of
a time travel device
and they're bouncing back and forth
through time which kind of brings us
into the next aspect of the time
variance authority which is to say
the nature of the multiverse is such
that new timelines are created in only
really a couple different ways as a time
variance authority is concerned
the first is through natural means which
is to say if you have a circumstance
whereby you have frank castle and most
of you guys know the punisher's family
was killed in central park in a mob
shooting that went wrong
a natural alteration to that timeline
would be that the shooting never
happened nobody intervened nobody
stepped in it's not like frank castle
came from the future into the past and
stopped the mobsters it's simply that
one of them said okay like we're not
going to do it here because there's
too many people we'll do this hit
somewhere else right that's a natural
occurrence there is an alternate reality
where that actually happened so that's a
natural formation of an alternate
timeline
then there is an artificial adjustment
to the timeline so if we use for example
the days of future past right that in
the main marvel universe the way that
timeline was supposed to unfold
is that mystique and her brotherhood of
evil mutants assassinated senator robert
kelly moore mctaggart and professor x of
the x-men
that led to the human population and the
government jump-starting the sentinel
program and the sentinels becoming
autonomous and then conquering north
america
and then you had rachel summers who was
the daughter of jean grey and cyclops in
that reality that sent the mind of kitty
pride
into the past to stop days of future
past from happening which he
successfully did that's an artificial
alteration of the timeline and so
because those different alterations
exist
especially those that exist artificially
the time variance authority doesn't
really care about the natural
adjustments to the timeline because
there really isn't a whole lot they can
do about that i mean i guess they could
but because it falls in the natural
process of things there isn't really a
reason for them to act
in terms of artificial adjustments to
the timeline somebody going back in time
and keeping something from happening
that's when the time variance authority
gets involved and what they'll do is
they'll look at that alteration
and they'll look at not just what
happened but the effects of what will
happen
right so if you ended up sending some
marvel character into the past
to stop an event from happening then the
time variance authority would look at
the immediate aftermath of that event as
well as the effect it'll have on the
entire timeline and if it looks like
it'll have a negative effect or if they
choose to act because the story requires
them to
then they'll step in now it doesn't
necessarily mean they'll send in their
time cops they will depending on the
nature of the threat but if it's too
extreme
they'll just they'll just get rid of the
timeline right they'll just go back and
go at some point in time and stop that
event from happening or wipe that person
from existence they'll snatch them up
they'll bring them to the time variance
authority headquarters
they'll put them on trial and they'll
say this is what you've done this is the
alteration it'll have to the timeline uh
so there's only a couple things that you
can do right either you can go back and
you can just keep yourself from doing
this you can
stop yourself from committing that act
but if that person proves to be
incorrigible and they're just like no
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this as
many times as i possibly can then the
time variance authority will destroy
them and they'll destroy their universe
now when a universe is destroyed by the
time variance authority and explicitly
when it's destroyed by the time variance
authority
it goes to their headquarters and then
any refuge that's left over will
basically be dropped into what's called
the nothingness beyond which is
essentially just kind of this
infinite expand of emptiness right so
think of like a trash can that goes on
forever now the reason why i say
when the tva destroys the universe
explicitly is because there are places
out there that when universes naturally
end they just kind of gravitate there
they just sort of go to that place
marvel depicts this in different ways
depending on different circumstances so
again
not an absolute thing but whenever the
tv8 wipes out a universe they bring it
here they kind of drop it off and and
dump it into this you know infinitely
expanding trash can now the
the next aspect of the time variance
authority is what's called the chrono
monitors
and these are the guys who figure out
that something's going on that shouldn't
be happening and so if you look at like
the loki tv series for excel
for example right the idea that when
everything popped off during avengers in
game and loki snatched up the tesseract
and disappeared that immediately changes
the timeline and because it changes the
timeline the chrono monitor for the
marvel cinematic universe because
there's only one for each universe the
chrono monitor would see that and then
immediately report it to his superiors
and his superiors would analyze the
timeline and say okay
what impact is this going to have and
then if the impact is is just minor and
it's not going to have
any real influence at all they might let
it slide but if it's gonna have a big
impact they'll snatch up loki like what
you saw in the or what you're seeing in
the loki tv show they'll bring them to
the time variance authority they'll put
them on trial
and then they'll do whatever they need
to do whether it's wiping out the
universe
simply just wiping loki from existence
or having him make amends in some form
or fashion the exact same thing happens
in the comics
right so um the crazy thing about this
is that when it comes to the alteration
or the creation of new timelines the
chrono monitors
can actually do that as well right so if
the chrono monitors are watching an
event unfold
and they say okay like this event is of
significance that we're going to create
or allow a new timeline to be created so
an example where peter parker chooses
not to give up the venom symbiote and he
basically goes forward as venom then
they would look at that and they would
say okay
this is not supposed to happen in the
main timeline but it is a significant
enough event that we're going to allow
it to play out and then from there it
would just go forward in a lot of ways
the chrono monitors are designed to
represent writers in marvel comics right
the the writing or the editing team
in marvel comics now again because of
the fact that the time variance
authority is a plot device you usually
just kind of see them
bouncing around marvel comics in a
couple different ways right they just
kind of appear in a story here or they
appear in a story there and there's not
a whole lot doing you know for example
like
they've appeared in the death block solo
series they appeared in some what if
stories they appeared in avengers
forever so when you had a whole bunch of
avengers showing up in just different
timelines all in the same place
uh when you go and you look at something
like unlimited access right access
basically being a character
that came out of the marvel vs dc
crossover way back in the 1990s you just
kind of see them showing up at different
points in time but
probably one of the more significant
moments with regards to the time
variance authority came with she-hulk
volume 2 issue number three back in
2005. now i don't mean to say that it's
a significant moment in so far as i
guess a universal reboot or anything
like that again the time variance
authority was never meant to be taken
seriously they're constantly tied up in
bureaucracy and then they're
exceedingly ineffective at their jobs
but the reason why this was kind of
significant here is because what had
happened is that in the aftermath of
house of m and really avengers
disassembled when hawkeye had basically
died sacrificing his life to try to stop
the scarlet witch
that uh she hulk had tried to slip him a
note and then tell him about what his
future was right when she had met him in
the past she tried to tell him like
you're gonna die or you're gonna end up
sacrificing your life
basically perishing during the events of
avengers disassembled here's a way to
try to get around that and it violated
the timeline the natural order of the
timeline is that he was supposed to die
and avengers disassembled and so she was
snatched up by the time variance
authority
and then brought to their headquarters
and put on trial but you end up seeing
them holding all different kinds of
characters here right iron man 2020
the two gun kid it's pretty cool it's a
it's a pretty cool and an interesting
little thing and that's kind of the
nature of the prison that when there's a
person who violates the time stream
and then they're in turn found guilty by
the time variance authority they're
usually just held in some kind of a
a temporal self and kept there sometimes
for all time until the end of the
universe uh sometimes for a period of uh
you know
for a number of years and then they're
re-educated as to why they should not
manipulate the time stream and then
they're repatriated back to their own
universe but one of the funny things is
while you did have justice peace you
also had justice love
and like she-hulk gets read the riot act
by justice love
[Laughter]
you know she's like sure you have
villains like kane to conquer that like
jump back and forth through time
but you guys are way worse than them
because you guys have inducted members
from the future
you've inducted members from the past
you've gone into the past you've killed
people in the past
like you started the destiny wars which
was basically a team of avengers from
across
like from across the entire timeline
that were traveling through time and you
had
multiple avengers from different
timelines all operating at the same time
like you guys have done nothing but just
manipulate and screw up time
over and over and over again so there's
a lot of hatred
for the avengers on behalf of the time
variants authority but again you know
ultimately she hopes
she will kind of argues her case and
then is essentially allowed to go
but uh but again you know the the
reality and how you're going to see
the time variance authority depicted in
the marvel cinematic universe is pretty
much exactly the way they are in the
comics that they're ineffective right
they're tied up in bureaucracy they
don't really do their jobs very well
and uh they they you know they suck
you know they're more of like comedic
relief like you're not going to walk
away taking them seriously but they are
a cool concept to involve my question is
how are they going to invoke and
probably wrap in
the time variance authority with things
like the omniversal development court
potentially the exiles the cool thing
about dealing with a team like that in
the marvel cinematic universe
is that you may just kind of see an
appearance a cameo by somebody who
exists out there right so like if you
see blink
who appears in the loki tv series that
means a few different things
one it means mutants now exist in the
marvel cinematic universe because
she's a mutant that can teleport and two
the exiles exist
which basically means a superhero like a
multiversal superhero team
largely composed of mutants that exist
to protect the multiverse so you might
see all kinds of stuff
if ever there were a time to give us a
cameo of mutants or the x-men
or or the the fantastic four that would
be it
right that would be it at the very least
to like reference them or something
along those lines whether the marvel
cinematic universe will or not i have no
idea but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you